now this is sort of a loaded question
but why are there so many bad romantic
comedies and then maybe it's just my own
opinion what are they doing wrong the
criteria that I used to select the
film's to go into this book were for the
stories had to embody and promote at
least one hopefully more of these four
qualities joy dignity passion and
integrity a lot of romantic comedies do
not therefore they are maybe
entertaining but they're shallow and
there's nothing wrong with fluff
entertainment that's perfectly fine but
the romantic comedies that move us that
that raise our spirits that thrill our
hearts are the ones that embody in some
fashion in some of the characters joy
dignity passion or integrity and those
are the ones we remember those are the
classics and here again I think if you
are looking to do a romantic comedy that
many people will relate to and many
people will remember and want to see
over and over again get one of those
four qualities in there at least one
with at least some of your main
characters once again nothing wrong with
having you know fluff fluff okay but I
like and you see that people continue to
like the romantic comedies that really
deal with the kind of love that uplifts
and not just romantic but also we have
familial we've got the best friend
romances in the book and at age
differences you know young love older
love age differences love so all kinds
of love but they need to embody one of
those four qualities to really be let's
say to have the romantic in all capital
letters
how would someone know that a script
that they've written is maybe shallow
versus having one or two or more of
those four qualities that's an excellent
question because it implies that we all
have the ability to a see our own work
with a clear eye and most of us don't
and that's why it's good to have you
know your friends or readers or other
people give you feedback whether you're
in a writing group or you're working
with you know some other people that are
that are doing that for you and with you
but I would say take a look at does
anybody in your story actually make a
positive change in their personality I
think there should always be some
element of sacrifice and remember that
the word sacrifice means to make sacred
so that could mean elevating someone's
opinion of themselves by saying you're
an amazing dancer if no one ever told
you that before or wow those things that
you've been doing for the kids you've
been helping that's incredible
some moment of recognition that lifts
somebody up to a higher plane if you've
got that in your story that it's not
going to be shallow okay okay
so let's say oh sorry Pluto in Seattle
like if we took one of the the scripts
at what point did did Tom Hanks
character maybe or even may Ryan did
they get lifted up to a higher plane
Sleepless in Seattle is such a popular
film so many people really really seem
to identify with it and liked it so much
I think part of that is because you have
two people one who's brokenhearted and
one who's dissatisfied with her fiance
and their relationship oh and then a
third person the little boy who wants a
new mommy right okay so you've got three
people who are wounded or troubled and
where you see them starting to rise up
when meg Ryan here's on the radio Tom
Hanks voice and talking about his wife
and the magic they had between them and
she realizes that when I want so that's
her first step upwards and then she
starts looking at her relationship is
there enough there to justify a marriage
Wow I want that kind of passion I heard
in that man's voice and then so she
sacrifices a sure thing to go after a
voice on a radio seriously
okay Tom Hanks then has to sacrifice his
clinging to his grief which is a very
natural thing that people tend to do but
he has to get over himself now not get
over the loss but get over himself so
you see both of them so you see both of
them consciously making a choice to
leave where they were and to take a step
up and then the little boy is so great
you know he what is he sacrificed Oh
nothing he's just out there manipulating
and pulling the strings but it's all for
a good cause